hello everyone and Welcome to our video
on skills required for an ml engineer
machine learning has been the Talk of
the Town lately every organization has
realized the potential of machine
learning in improving their business
objectives and attaining their
Enterprise goals this expanding demand
has led to a lot of people applying for
machine learning jobs and upskilling
themselves in the field of machine
learning you can take up this growing
opportunity in the field of machine
learning and utilize it to lend yourself
a very challenging fulfilling and high
paying job in this video we will be
breaking down in complete detail each
and every skill that you would need in
order to correct the machine learning
engineer job interview well ml is not
just a passing Trend it's a seismic
shift that is reshaping a world and
creating new avenues for Innovation and
Discovery so by embracing a career in ml
you become part of dynamic field that
thrives on solving complex problem
pushing boundaries and making a profound
impact on society so the demand for ML
professional is skyrocketing across
industries from Healthcare and finance
to entertainment and transportation
organizations are actively seeking
talented individuals who can harness the
power of AI to drive their business
forward but what skill does it takes to
become an ml engineer how can you embark
on this thrilling Journey we have the
answers to all your questions also
accelerate your career in Ai and ml with
our comprehensive postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning gain
expertise in machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
alumni membership and ask me anything
sessions by IBM with three Capstone
projects and 25 plus industry projects
using real data sets from Twitter Uber
and more you will gain practical
experience master classes by Caltech
faculty and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education simply learns job assist help
you get noticed by Leading companies
this program covers python supervised
and unsupervised learning NLP neural
networks computer Visions gns Keras
tensorflow and many more other skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is in the
description box below so without any
further delay let's get started to
become a machine learning engineer you
need a combination of technical skills
non-technical skills and some bonus
skills so here are some essential skills
required to pursue a career as an ml
engineer so first we will talk about
some technical skills to become a ml
engineer so first one in the list is
programming languages strong programming
skills are essential you should be
proficient in at least one programming
languages such as python or r python is
widely used in the ml Community due to
its Rich libraries that is numpy pandas
tensorflow and pytorch that supports ml
tasks and the second on the list is
machine learning algorithms and
techniques you should have a solid
understanding of various ml algorithms
such as linear regression logistic
regression decision trees random Forest
neural network and deep learner
familiarize yourself with the principles
Behind These algorithms their pros and
cons and when to use them so third one
on the list is data pre-processing ml
models require clean and well prepared
data you should know how to handle
missing data deal with normalize and
standardize data and the finalists
perform feature engineering
understanding data preprocessing
technique is crucial for Effective ml
model training and the fourth one is
data manipulation and Analysis data is
the foundation of ml model you should be
skilled in the data manipulation and
Analysis using libraries like numpy and
pandas this includes cleaning and trans
developing data exploratory data
analysis which is Eda and understanding
the statical properties of the data and
the fifth one is machine learning
libraries and Frameworks familiarity
with popular ml libraries and framework
is essential some some commonly used one
include numpy pandas tensorflow and Pi
dot this Library provides
pre-implemented ml algorithms neural
network architectures and tools for
model training and evaluation now that
we have seen the Technical Machine
learning engineering skills let us have
a look at the non-technical machine
learning skills so the first one is
industry knowledge machine learning
projects that effectively tackle genuine
challenges are likely to achieve great
success regardless of the industry you
are involved in it is crucial to have a
comprehensive understanding of its
operation and identify ways to optimize
business outcomes and the second one on
the list is effective communication
effective communication plays a crucial
role in facilating these interactions
companies seeking skill ml engineer
value candidates who can effectively
convey technical discoveries to
non-technical terms like marketing or
sales demonstrating Clarity and fluency
in their explanation moving forward
let's see some bonus skills to become a
ml engineer the first one on the list is
reinforcement learning in 2023
reinforcement learning emerge as a
catalyst for numerous captivating
advancement in deep learning and
artificial intelligence to pursue a
career in robotics self-driving cars or
any other AI related feed it is crucial
to comprehend this concept and the
second on the list is computer vision
computer vision and machine learning are
fundamental branches of computer science
that can independently fuel highly
Advanced system relying on CV and ml
algorithm however their combination has
a potential to unlock the greater even
possibilities and achievements so
remember that the field of ml is
constantly evolving through continuous
learning and staying updated with the
latest development and the research
papers are essential to be the Practical
so that's all we had for you in this
video we can call it a wrap now if you
still have any question or doubt let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of expert will help you at the
earlier thank you so much for being here
today we'll see you next time until then
stay safe and keep learning with simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here